this is a production of cornell
university
uh hi i'm bruce wright i'm a professor
in horticulture
and
my my work is all in great breathing
great genetics
we're at a no spray disease resistance
breathing block here
my responsibilities are to both develop
new grape varieties for eastern
viticulture especially for new york and
also study the genetics of underlying
traits traits of great importance such
as
such as disease resistance
winter hardiness
and
quality which goes hand in hand with the
two
so great breathing at
new york state agricultural experiment
station we're now cornell agritech began
around 1885
and initially the primary goal was to
breed table grapes
for many years it was a table grape
breathing program and later in the early
mid 1900s it was a seedless
table seedless grape breathing program
it wasn't really until 1940s or 50s that
the project turned to wine grape
breathing
and most of the effort now more than
two-thirds of the effort
uh is in wine grape breathing for
disease resistance heartiness
and factors that make it easy to
harvest and grow consistently
in new york so
we're standing at a no spray breathing
block that was
first planted in the late 80s early
1990s
and
in this block
we took
the
most
resilient
selections that we could find in the
program selections that were grown under
neglect
almost under no spray conditions but
germplasm that i found in the program
when i first started that was really
just held for use in germplasm
collections i scoured through that
material to find the most disease
resistant material possible and started
to grow it actively under no spray
conditions
we developed mapping populations we
developed in our program some of the
first genetic maps
that were published in grapevines first
with isozymes then with rapids more
recently with gbs snip based markers and
ramp seat based markers
so a variety of technologies have come
along to improve the mapping and the
work to locate genes for traits of
interest in the program
so
early on it was very empirical in
approach
if it was disease resistant in the
nursery it would make it out to a
permanent vineyard to this site it would
be tested
and crosses would be made with higher
quality grapes to combine quality with
resistance that came from the many wild
species that we utilize in the program
the vitus gen projects came along two
different usda funded
specialty crop research initiative
projects
of which i co-lead the second one i was
leader of the first one
and with the team of fantastic
scientists that we work work with
scientists from usda scientists from
across the country
we've developed a very directed approach
to stacking genes for disease resistance
and to studying genes for
that relate to fruit quality to acidity
and other characteristics of fruit
quality
i think the best instances i can
describe for you are disease resistance
genes some of which were
found within our project within our
vitisgen project some of which were
found here
located in
germplasm that we were
growing
here at cornell agritech
and
others of which we've acquired and
utilized
and have developed good marker systems
to identify
the macro systems allow us to um to
stack these genes together for use in
the program we would not possibly be
able to combine different sources of
resistance without having the markers
that we have now the markers and the
combination of genes to me are really
important to try to develop long-term
stability and durability of the
resistance genes we do know that over
time
the activity of these genes can erode
we've seen
some of these genes
uh that seemed ironclad at the very
start
now
uh though they are powdery mildew
resistance genes we've seen some powdery
mildew growing on vines that that we
know harbor these genes
not a lot it's still a very useful
source
but we do know pathogens can mutate and
overcome these resistance genes
so uh here we are june 15th and we're
wrapping up our crossing season uh we've
made
more than 20 different crosses i i don't
have the exact tally but i want since
it's crossing season grapes are
flowering all around us
these are grape flowers
not the easiest things to work with
they're very small and they are perfect
flowers they have both viable pollen as
well as
stigma style ovary
and almost all cultivated grapes have
perfect flowers
but in the wild vines
of each species are either male or
female
within the vitisgen project my
colleagues
zoo chang
chi sun landscape davidson jason londo
have studied the structure of the
hermaphrodite locus the flower sex locus
and grapes and the paper was just
published
a couple of months ago in proceedings of
the national academy of sciences based
on this study which to to me tells you a
lot about the domestication of grapes
and the fact that there were two
different
instances of um
the
of the
arising of hermaphrodite flowers in
these species that either were male
vines or female vines so
take a look for that paper if you're
interested in an in-depth
uh analysis
this particular dead vine came to me as
a seed stock from hungary
where a muscadine grape
from down in southern united states a 40
chromosome species was hybridized in the
1920s early 1920s late teens or so over
a century ago to make a cross with bunch
grapes
most of our grape species have 38
chromosomes so very difficult cross to
make some viable progeny were obtained
and later
found their way to a lamb bouquet in
southern france who made further crosses
as he noticed that these
hybrids between muscadines and vinifera
had high levels of powdery mildew
resistance
studies were made the gene was located
it's a very strong locus for powdery
mildew resistance
adjacent to that locus is another very
strong gene for
downy mildew resistance
and
eventually that source i then utilize in
the 1980s and 90s
that source of powdery mildew resistance
which had now been introgressed into a
background which i could cross with
freely
found its way into some slightly more
winter hardy germplasm
which for a colleague of mine in hungary
paul cosma shared with me
and this is
some of the germplasm he shared with me
a vine that's struggling to survive
after mild winters
but the first year that it did produce
flowers after a very mild winter
i jumped on those flowers sight unseen i
knew the vines were powdery mildew
resistant
and i've been successful
in introducing this gene those two gene
locus powdery and downy mildew
resistance combined into more
uh well-adapted germplasm which i'll
show you next
so with the seeds that i obtained from
my colleague in hungary
the first couple of years they had a
chance to flower they did not again too
much winter damage but in 2006
they did flower
and i crossed them with other disease
resistant germplasm with reasonable
quality good winter hardiness and this
is one of the seedlings that then
resulted we have a plot here of six
vines of new york 06 5146
which is highly disease resistant it
combines by the scenarios ren2 locus for
powdery mildew resistance with the
resistance of the muscadine grape and
this is a red wine grape with some
chocolate and raspberry notes that's
gone out for trials more broadly beyond
cornell
so in this in this vineyard as you can
see we've placed qr codes here and
throughout the vineyard
and we're using
an imaging system a camera drawn on an
atv to image these vines
and one project is aimed at detecting
phylloxera on leaf tissue phylloxera
which is an important
insect has has in the past wiped out
european viticulture
and we're trying to envision phylloxera
on
leaf tissue because that can be a
problem with hybrid grapes
and using
the imaging system and algorithms to
pick out leaf phylloxera on tissues
we're trying to quantify that
in this mapping population and study the
genetics of phylloxera resistance
in addition we're cooperating with katie
gold an assistant professor in plant
pathology here at cornell on use of
spectral analyses
uv near-infrared visible spectra
analyses to to understand physical
physiochemical properties of leaf and
developing fruit tissues this location i
wanted to um to show you not necessarily
the oldest vine in the program but one
of the vines with the biggest trunk that
i i've ever grown
we just don't seem to grow trunks like
this in new york state this is a vine i
picked out early on
to initiate some of the disease
resistance breathing here it was growing
so well
uh winter hardiness-wise and disease
resistance-wise
it was growing so well under neglect
we've located uh from the by the
scenario parents of this
the ren2 locus for powdery mildew
resistance this is
the source source vine
for that study
and
this one happens to be a male so no
fruit quality to judge
but
we come such a long ways in the program
from the wild grapes that we started
with in the 1800s late 1800s
1900s
and to the present day
where we're now domesticating these wild
species and this uh rupestris by cenaria
hybrid the muscadine grape a couple of
uh species from from
uh china by this piazzesky by this roman
eddie eye
our sources of disease resistance genes
that we utilize
um
we're
bringing these into the program
and in the course of uh domesticating
these wild species
we've developed
somewhere over 60 different grape
varieties
in my time
at cornell agritech it's more than 10
different grape varieties that we've
developed mostly wine grapes but everest
seedless a jumbo sized
concord type seedless grape
was the last one we released uh probably
the first seedless grape in about 20
years to to be released from the program
it happens to be a tetraploid grape so
associated with having doubled number of
chromosomes you have a very large berry
size an average of five to seven grams
per berry
similar flavor to concord but twice the
size of a concord berry and seedless
wine grapes tramanet was one of our most
successful is a release from 1996
and
20 years later or so it was named
the outstanding fruit cultivar by the
american society for horticultural
sciences fruit breeding working group
it's
garnered major awards it's very similar
in wine quality to its coverts
tremendous parent so you could almost
not tell the difference with converts
tremendous yet it's much more winter
hardy much more disease resistant than
gewurztraminer
so that's been widely grown in new york
and elsewhere
it's great fun to go to the wineries and
see
tramanet selling at many wineries in the
finger lakes and elsewhere
in addition
some more recent releases include
aramella a highly aromatic aromatic
seedling of tramanette
very much more winter hardy even than
traminette and arendelle the first
cultivar that we named out of this no
spray breathing block a red wine grape
with high levels of disease resistance
and several wineries in new york kansas
and virginia are making very good wines
now with arendelle
each year each of these varieties is
responsible for between 5 and 15 million
dollars worth of wine production just
in new york state alone
so
so we see a
over time a cumulative economic impact
in the tens of millions of dollars
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu